قال رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه
عبد الحميد دبيبه ان حكومته ترفض المراحل
الانتقاليه والحكومات الموازيه وان
الانتخابات وفق قوانين انتخابيه عادله هي
الوسيله الوحيده لاستقرار ليبيا وكان ذلك
خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات
فالرسائل التي حرصت ببيبه على توجيهها في
اجتماع حكومته وما خلفيات تحذير المبعوث
الاممي الى ليبيا من وجود حكومتين في
البلاد وما هو افق حلول الازمه السياسيه
في ليبيا بالنظر الى المواقف المتباينه
للاطراف السياسيه والعسكريه الليبيه
[موسيقى]
ربما يريد ان يجري هذه الاجتماعات في
اجواء يعني
في الجبل الغربي خاصه لانه يعني يبسط
سيطرته على هذا المكان فبالتالي هو يريد
ان يظهر بانه موجود في المنطقه الغربيه
ليس في طرابلس فقط وانما في كل المنطقه
الغربيه حكومه عبد الحميد دبيب تفتخر
بانها في السنتين الماضيتين كانت الامور
افضل من سوابقها في ليبيا يعني هناك شبه
استقرار يقول لاني لن اترك الحكم الان لن
ارضى بحكومه موازيه لن ارضى بقوانين تفصل
على بعض الاطراف كما ذكر هو يقول انا
ساذهب بعث الامميه انا جئت ضمن اتفاق جنيف
غير هذا لن يكون هناك خروج فبالتالي ما
حدث في بوزنيقه
سته زائد سته كان يتحدث عن حكومه جديده هو
يرفض كذلك هذه الحكومه الجديده فبالتالي
هو يصر على هذا المسار اللي هو بداوا من
ذو الب دايه انه لن يترك هذا الحكم الا
بانتخابات حره ونزيهه وتاتي شرعيه جديده
هو يرى انه يمثل الشرعيه يمثل كل ليبيا
هناك توافق على قيادته من الخارج ومن
الداخل علاقته مميزه مع كافه كثير من
القوى خاصه الدول الاوروبيه وتركيا وكذلك
الامم المتحده ولذلك هو يرى ان ازاحه هذه
الحكومه التي اوصلت البلاد الى نوع من
الاستقرار سيدخل البلاد مره اخرى في
الفوضى وعوده مراكز القوه للتاثير على سير
الامور وعلى الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
بين خالد المشري وعقيله صالح سيدخل البلاد
في ازمه جديده باستبعاد حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه هناك اطراف موجوده على الساحه
ويجب التشاور معها ولذلك هو
يخشى اخشى
ان مع المجلس
الاعلى في ايجاد حكومه حكومه اي نوع من
الحكومه بالتالي ستخلق مشاكل جديده ليبيا
في غنى عنها فهو رفض يعني مخرجات سته زائد
سته لكن بطريقه دبلوماسيه يعني بمعنى
سيطره مجلس النواب والمجلس الاعلى للدوله
على السلطه التشريعيه لن يتيح له ان يرسم
المسار السياسي كافر فبالتالي البعد
القانوني هنا لا يكفي يعني السلاح الذي
يملكه مجلس الدوله ومجلس النواب هو اصدار
القوانين لكن هذه اصدار القوانين هذا لن
يكفي بالنسبه لعبد الله بتيلي فبالتالي هو
يسقط هذه الورقه من ايديهم هي الاشكال
الان في قضيتين اساسيتين قضيه الاولى هي
قضيه
سعه
قدره هذه القوانين على استيعاب جميع
الاطراف السياسيه في العمليه الانتخابيه
واحد اثنين اصرار عديله صالح وخالد المشري
على حكومه الثانيه ايبدو ان بيتي لهذا
الامر مرفوض تماما عنده الامور المتحده لن
تدعم اي عمليه قد تؤدي الى ازمه جديده في
ليبيا
[موسيقى]
الحل هو مشاركه سياسيه واسعه للاطراف التي
تملك القوه على الارض بما في ذلك عديله
صالح وخالد المشري بحجم القوه التي
يملكونها وليس بقوه التشريع الذي يمثلنا
لان اذا هناك توافق بين القوى السياسيه
قبل ان يكون هناك تشريعات تصدر من مجلس
النواب او غيره لن يكون هناك حل اذا
الاطراف
وهذا حدث في الماضي مرات ومرات اذا لا
يوجد قوه حتى لا
هي تحاول هي تجمع الاطراف هي تحاور الجميع
تتوصل الى توافقات بينهم وتطرح عليهم
الامم المتحده تطرح تقدم المبادرات لكنها
لا تجبر لا تستطيع ان تجبر لان المخلص
سيكون اقليمي وليس دولي وليس محلي بمعنى
التغيرات الاقليميه هي التي ستجبر الاطراف
على تغيير وعيها بالمشهد لان لا احد ينكر
تاثير مصر وتركيا في ليبيا بل قوه مصر
وتركيا في ليبيا هو حقيقيه على الارض وهذا
قد يجبر الاطراف الليبيه على ايجاد حل
فاذا كان هناك توافق اقليمي وهو الان يبدو
ان هناك توافقا اقليميا او قريبا من
الاقتراب مصر مع مع تركيا وكذلك الدوري
الايجابي الذي تلعبه الجزائر وتونس يعني
من مصلحه البلدين ان يكون هناك استقرار في
ليبيا